[SOUND]
>> What's on your mind?
>> Well, so I've been chatting
a lot with the developer about
the order of certain events
which got me thinking.
Let's say you have a user.
>> Hm-hm.
>> And the user does a couple of edits.
If there any way you can know how
Firebase sends these edits to the server
or what order they're processed in, or
what order they'll trigger
event listeners in?
>> I was just working through some
of these scenarios earlier today.
It turns out that Firebase does have
what they call Event Guarantees.
Which are guarantees about how
Firebase will handle your data.
Let's take a look.
>> Firebase provides several related
guarantees for database events.
All Firebase operations
performed locally by your app
will immediately fire events.
Events are notifications such
as a child node was added or
a child node was changed.
This is helpful when there
is network latency or
loss in internet connectivity.
In these situations,
when connectivity is reestablished,
the app will receive
the appropriate set of events and
all the clients will catch up
with the current server state.
Another guarantee is that
of Eventual Consistency.
This means that events will eventually
reflect the correct state of the data
even when temporary events such
as separate clients writing
similar changes to the database
at approximately the same time,
prevents an immediate
update to the database.
After some time passes,
the database will become
consistent with all the changes.
A third guarantee is Event Order.
Rights from a single client will
always be written in to the server and
broadcast out to other users in order.
If a single client performs right
operations to three locations in its
Firebase database,
those three operations will be delivered
to all currently connected clients
in the same order that
the originating client sent them in.
Finally, Firebase guarantees that
whenever something is read from
the database with a value
event type object.
For example, add value event listener or
add listener for
single value event,
it is triggered last.
This is in the case where you have
both child event listeners and
value event listeners
on the same location.
The child event listeners
will be triggered first.
So when data is stored or when it
changes the order is, data is written or
updated, the data is then
synchronized to a data snapshot,
child events are triggered, and
then the value events are triggered.